startup is like a rollercoaster
and every day you mention what keep me
at night every day something else
and and you know one day you are at the
top
and and feeling here you are the
luckiest thing that everything is in
line and all the stars are aligned and
things are happening and one day is like
getting rejection or something didn't
work as you wanted
and and being you know
can can't sleep at night
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders the
combination of technology and health is
a fascinating one and one that changes
literally all of our lives
meet hillary goldman aslan
hilar holds a dwell bachelor's degree in
law and llb and business administration
bba along with a masters of law from tel
aviv university specializing in
commercial law after years of leading
high-tech companies focused on med tech
hila founded dia imaging analysis she
has led the company from the idea
through proof of concept product
development building a team regulation
raising capital and validation to
commercial partnerships with leading
vendors such as ge healthcare phillips
and ibm
um
dia analysis imaging analysis and
understanding the way that artificial
intelligence is relevant in ultrasounds
and anything that has to do with imaging
and with identifying
what's happening and how to take better
care of ourselves so maybe you can share
with me just a little bit about about
yourself and
you've been with dia for quite some time
i believe you joined about 11 years ago
as as co-founder and ceo
what what how did you even get into this
world of of imaging analysis and
artificial intelligence
yeah so in my case saying it was a
and it wasn't planned and i think the
the the best thing in life are usually
not planned
and
i i'm my background day i studied my
first degree as a in business as well as
law
and my second degree was a commercial
and
and i practiced law only in the tech
area
industry
doing ipos investment a commercial
agreements
and sitting on boards go doing a all the
process of of going public
and through this process and working
with a lot of tech companies i realized
that i'm i don't want to be a lawyer as
a main professional
and this is when i started to move to
the tech
side of things
and i started as business business
development manager in fintech company
and then
managing a
few companies in incubator programs here
in israel
and then i met my partner my co-founder
mikhail she is
a bioengineering background
and i met her right when she finished
her master's degree around the
image processing
in medical imaging especially
specifically in cardiac ulcers and this
is where we we found out that she's
bringing the technology and clinical
things inside of things and i'm bringing
the business side of things
and this is how it is started
and way early to the market before
anybody talked about ai
and
only thinking about how you know
automating the workflows and
analysis of ultrasound images
which commonly being done by visual
estimation just looking at the pictures
and analyzing what's there
and this this is how we we built the
initially
a very naive i would say a very
enthusiastic and still very very
enthusiastic even now
and but with a great passion and and
seeing clearly the need for automation
in this area
right and obviously in the in the last
10 years um really really five years and
and la and after obviously the i is
already up and running we're seeing
you know a wave of of entrepreneurs that
are coming and are leveraging the use of
technology in this case ai to to work on
these problems
tell me a little bit about
the challenges that this world presents
to a technologist right so you're coming
and you're saying we have that we have
it we have an interesting technology
we have a real human pain this in fact
this human pain may lead to life and
death or you know in in a better
scenario a quality of life situation
where you're
checking how how well a person can live
and and what are sort of the challenges
in building a product like this because
from looking at a lot of other
software-based products you know the
main challenge is how do how do i reduce
my cost of acquisition and get my users
to give me a good nps score but this is
not really the same
question here so because what challenges
do we present so i think because we are
in the clinical
a space in medical space and the
challenges are more in terms of adaption
but in terms of also how can i validate
the the technology
from a user perspective and how can i
trust it
because when you're anything that it's
not medical you just try it and see if
it's good for you and if it's giving you
value and pretty fast you you know if
this is something you want to use
in the medical space
you know because the there is regulation
processes like fda
and even if you have an fda approved
solution still physicians
um you know testing a validating
a challenging technology there because
as you mentioned it's it can be live for
that situation
and also the adoption of new technology
in some cases is a barrier because the
physicians are used to do things in a
certain way and when you're bringing new
technology like ai for example and
saying okay this is new thing that you
can use with your patient making
decisions
then you know they they starting to
hesitate at the beginning not sure how
can i use it how can i
how can i trust it i think that those
are the barriers that you can see in the
medical space which i don't think you
see in other spaces
and so
if we're looking now at this question of
of trust building especially with people
that are in the field that you know
they've worked for many many years to
come up with with the insights and then
and the knowledge to be able to to come
up with interesting conclusions
you know you're looking at this let's
say 10 years ago when you're even trying
to figure out whether this is something
that can be integrated
what are sort of the drawbacks or the
pushbacks that you're receiving from
from people in the industry in the in
the health industry so
going back and then this is a
and it's again as you mentioned it's
almost a decade
and
i think there are two things that we saw
evolving through the last 10 years
the first thing was
that physicians came and say i don't
need this
i can do everything by eyeballing i can
look at images this is my my work this
is what i do every day
i my own ai
got used to looking at images
and i don't need any help
and i don't understand why i need you
know ai which fro from my perspective ai
is mainly smart automation
and and i don't know why you need it
that was the first reaction from the
industry
because you know we are combining our ai
solution within ultrasound devices or as
part of the healthcare ide systems
what we heard back then was
i can do it myself if i want to more of
a what we call nih thing not invented
here so why why should i use a third
party we are a technology company we are
a development company we will do
whatever we want and if we don't see the
need
and you know
probably we don't need you guys so that
was the reaction admission
now through time what we saw
was a very interesting thing the first
thing that happened
during the that time is the change in
generation of physicians
the new generation of physician
that grew up with cell phones automation
trying new things every day actually
apps
video games you name it
we're thinking the other way around like
how can you help me make things more
automated how can you provide me more
solution that will make my life easier
will make me make a decision based on
more objective information than
subjective eyeballing information that
was the first change that we saw
the second change that we saw it was
within the actual companies the industry
that came along and after i would say 10
years
and so in the last few years saying
you know
we cannot do all that on our own you
know we can pick and choose what to
develop our own but if we want to get
into the market
fast and bring our users fast solution
that will automate some of their
processes make it more objective and
that they can trust and make better
decisions we must work with third-party
solution
to accelerate the adoption in the market
and are present in the market in this
space now you know what happened with ai
during the last 10 years so from being
almost nothing starting to get what this
what what can we do with that and now
what we're seeing in the market is how
can i get more of it
so that is the transaction that we we we
saw during the
from the time that we were established
until now
okay and now if we're looking at you
know this question of trust is an
important one especially as we're saying
that there's a few players in the field
and now you have a um
hospital a private clinic et cetera that
is that that wants to there there is a
you know um
a consumer-wide understanding that we
want to leverage third-party technology
but now we have to make some decisions
right and you know this is not
a traditional decision to buy software
here you're going to commit to a company
probably i'm assuming that that one
company is going to win the contract
what how do they think about it what is
sort of what are the things that make
them
want one company versus another as
they're integrating into their
healthcare first thing is validation so
they want to see publications they want
to see your research your your results
how did you validate your your results
what what what kind of data did you use
how you annotate it what did you compare
it to
and so that's for sure for physicians uh
that eventually are the buyers of those
ai solution are the first questions that
they are asking and wants you to
validate with first adoption and the
doctors you need to give them trial
periods they want to try it they want to
try they want it to compare it they want
to feel it
and to compare it to the traditional
ways they're doing of they're doing the
ways that they're doing it traditionally
and and this is how they they they get
the the trust and and make a decision
got it and so if we're looking at now
this journey as a leader now in you know
in the space
and you're thinking about you know the
way that your technology can potentially
impact
you know the the way that these doctors
are working what are the different
considerations that are keeping you up
at night you know now from a you know
from a domain leadership perspective so
i i i think that uh i can tell you what
excites me
for example when during kovid when our
solution
was used
as part of g handle ultrasound device
and we have a cardiac solution that help
monitor
and track
a trends of of patient's heart
and and you know we ultrasound it
doesn't have any radiation so you can do
it as much as you want like every hour
you can check the patient and look at
the heart and see like what what
happened like what change
if my my treatment is working if i have
to you know give the patient more fluids
if i have to change my medicine and what
we we got
that was very exciting was that we saw a
tweet by a physician in uk
using our solution within those handheld
devices by ge
and tweeting that the vivo who is that
that's the name of our product
what was helping me in the icu with
covet patient monitoring patient's heart
on it
on a consistent
and and and a way
and and when you see that this is not a
physician that we are paying him
anything
we don't know him even we never met him
and then seen that kind of information
three months into coffee
that's that's worth like that that's the
the case with you when you are starting
to remember why you're doing what you're
doing because you know startup is like a
rollercoaster
and every day you mention what keep me
at night every day something else
and and you know one day you are at the
top
and and feeling here you are the
luckiest thing that everything is in
line and all the stars are aligned and
things are happening and one day is like
getting rejection or something didn't
work as you wanted
and and being you know
can can't sleep at night as you as you
mentioned but having that small tweet
of a physician saying okay i used that
that helped me that helped my my passion
that that's what's keep us
going forward and being excited about
what we're doing
amazing and still 10 years into the
journey
i assume that there are some some
changes that the company makes
in the life cycle from validation of the
idea to you know growth and saying okay
can we actually you know make this make
this a reality to now say okay how can
we continue to to grow in the market
where are you now with the where is the
dna right now we have eight fda and c
marked solutions that are out there in
the market
we partner with more than 12 channel
partners like ge phillips connie
caminolta ibm and so forth
uh that adopting our solution adding the
our solution to their ultrasound devices
or healthcare id systems
and we're seeing traction for the market
we have more than 4 000 end users
available in more than 20 countries a
growing our team they had the last day
we we closed the around of the big round
of investment
and and basically it's scaling like now
we are at the scaling position
and on the other hand we are not a one
product company
and we will always continue to invest in
r d
adding more solution to the market
ultrasound is a big market that in terms
of roadmap you know we it can feed us
for 20 years now
uh so we mainly our channel challenges
are how to prioritize what to do next
so heavily investing in the r d and and
releasing a new solution to the market
but at the same time pushing our fda
approved solution into the market
through our channel partnership and
commercial activities
right and if we're looking if you're now
you're thinking about impact scale and
and you know the way that you're
thinking strategically about scaling
this what are the different tactics that
you can use
as the ceo here to get this to as many
hospitals as possible
you know we we choose a
unique way of
entering the market and that was through
channel partners and not going direct to
hospitals and knocking on doors
i think uh
going
forward and we've proven that that
business model is working
that
you know that's the fastest way to get
into the market so we're going to
continue investing those partnership and
expanding our partnership portfolio
at the same time you know a lot of
marketing activities being present
hearing the voice of the
users which are the physicians
and making sure
that we are aligned with the trends
and the pain points
and
but basically scaling also in personnel
and being innovative all the time you
know it's again it's not the one one
thing solution when we're talking with
our end users
they're always asking like can you do
that can you bring us
that solution this solution this is what
we are looking for this is the missing
part that we're a heading so
that's how we we we navigate ourselves
in terms of scaling and
expanding
do people on on the team idea
is it is it more of a startup mentality
more of a
you know of a robust tech company where
where how how do you see your own team
operating today
i think it's
still more of a very start-up
culture and dna
and and i hope it will be that way as
much as possible because it's hard when
you bring in more people
a you're becoming a
um
more i would not say more corporate but
they starting to adopt corporate
processes
and in a lot of the cases when when we
bring in people from corporate companies
and you know the first meeting that i'm
i'm having with them is i know you want
to add processes to the company and
think do things as you learn to do in
the big corporate
but just try to be very sensitive about
what must have at this stage and what is
nice to have because otherwise you will
kill the company
and and and we really try to only you
know only touch and and adopt those
things that
definitely when you're scaling you need
to be you you have to bring more
processes in order to make things happen
faster and in the right way especially
working with these big corporate
companies like philips tree conica ibm
but on the other
hand keeping it still robust innovative
open discussions and and fast like
changing and passing the stick between
one to each other very fast
[Music]
so we talked about you know the
formation the market where we were 10
years ago the potential of such a
technology we then talked a little bit
about you know the challenges that that
that are presented in in a company like
this whether it be you know the growth
of a company and its culture all the way
to how do you gain trust of the
customers
and and just the tiny bit we touched on
on the strategy and go to market
and the most important which which i
love closing the loop with this you know
it's the the mission the schlicht
you know where where are you
in this whole big puzzle what is the
most passionate about a
india and in general about healthcare
companies is that you're really you know
every person in dia
knows that his role impacts patients and
physicians
and if you look at every role
you know
from marketing to development
each one is eventually presenting and
working on
a product and delivery of a product that
will impact lives
so when r d people are working on their
everyday
tasks they're looking at ultrasound
images which are patients
actual hearts or other anatomic areas
when you're starting to work on a white
paper or a case study
to present to in a conference you are
actually talking about case studies of
patients and things that actually happen
so i think the impact that each and
every person at the company have
on lives and on the next generation of
technology in the imaging space is
unique
and that's what also a keep people stay
here and enjoy their work
fantastic amazing illa i really want to
thank you for your time in this episode
for the work that you're doing with dia
i'm looking back 10 years ago and i'm
asking myself this question today you
know how
how
what skills do i have to now look at the
world and say this is there's a way
there's a technology that i can leverage
to disrupt something that is as
important as as imaging analysis
especially when it comes to health care
and and i'm always inspired by these
stories um of of companies like dia and
how you start out you know in a time
where you know yeah ai was starting to
be talked about and and but but you know
the integration and healthcare and the
edu and educating the market wasn't
trivial and so it's very very cool to to
visit back and that's why i also enjoyed
hearing back a lot about the beginning
of the journey and what led to it and
how do you actually gain the trust and
you know questions that i think today we
take a little bit for granted where many
radiologists and many doctors they
understand
the use of third-party applications in
their work but you know 20 years ago
i don't think many
agreed with this idea that somebody else
will come and will give them insight
into how they're running and so i think
that you're in a it's such an exciting
field obviously you know making an
impact saving lives and improving
people's lives and so thank you very
much and stay safe and stay healthy and
best of luck with thank you thank you
for having me
[Music]
you